let's talk about something funny yes and
uh check this out this is amazing
james lindsey was at death star
conceptual james yeah tweeted lol woke
at andrew doyle
so those aren't familiar andrew doyle
runs a parody twitter account called
titanium mcgrath
and when i saw this tweet he
says lol woke and it's he's quoting
bronco bookstore
who said we've put together a section at
the bronco bookstore of books
that focus on diversity equity and
inclusivity
check it out and get the conversation
started all books are also available on
our website
can i can i can i talk about this a
little bit sure because i feel like he
kind of bury the lead up a little bit on
this one
because this looks like a great display
so if you click it and look at it this
is fantastic we can see stacey
abrams look at this oh yeah i can do
that how to be an anti-racist
racist by ibrahimovic wonderful
instruction i'm just surprised you know
white fragility isn't right here
it's time to talk it's time to listen
and this bookstore is so
woke you want to know how woke they are
tim
look at this book here in the right hand
corner it is a book that is literally
called
woke and you guys know who it's by right
that is by
our favorite blonde haired bespectacled
lady on twitter
miss titania mcgrath titania my bad
she's named after the name he's a he's
um
so this guy andrew doyle is a literature
expert and he read a lot of shakespeare
and titania titania my gosh
is the queen of the fairies so he picked
her name
and he uses her to virtue signal loudly
and this is his book
woke it's satire okay andrew doyle
the joke is i guess the humorous moment
is that they created this display of
actual woke books yep it's time to talk
and listen lead from the outside stacey
abrams and they put a satirical
anti-sjw book which mocks them to no end
and we get jarvis dupont jarvis dupont
is also a fake sjw on twitter he's um
how many followers he's your boyfriend i
guess
is he i don't know he's got 126 000
followers
he says i use my white privilege as a
raft to transport minorities from the
cave of oppression
to the island of equal prosperity trans
she her lesbian
we're going to get in trouble jarvis
says yes
good to see titania mcgrath getting at
least a small fraction of the
recognition she deserves
although disappointing to not see her on
the plinth
do better next time bronco bookstore let
me open
let me show you let me show you what
happens when you open titanium mcgrath
titania is following no one
and that's what you get whoa yeah
temporary restriction
they really don't like the prominence of
andrew doyle's satirical creation i love
it
check this out caution this account is
temporarily restricted are we ready
let's view the profile so titanium
there she is she's so lovely with her
glasses so check this out
tight you guys know titania you probably
know titania yet we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna talk about titania i guess
for now because
i think it's hilarious this book is is
up there and there are some new jokes
from
andrew doyle titania says i have written
a book for children
it's called my first little book of
intersectional activism
the next generation must be taught to
think exactly like me
pre-order immediately and joseph stalin
is right there
oh my gosh so there's a bunch of names
um
free larsen where really down at the
bottom left corner
oh yeah brie larson congratulations
greta tunberg joseph stalin oh my god
linda sarsour
jessica yanni very cool just a who's who
yeah somebody highlighted joseph stalin
right there joseph stalin oh this is
enjoyable
those are your intersectional activists
and there was a
i'll show you a funny tweet from titania
where is that one
uh here we go future generations will
thank us
if we successfully eliminate
heterosexuality yes preach
queen wait how does that work that's
exactly it doesn't that's exactly the
point
i know so anyway you guys know you
probably have heard of titania we've
talked about titania before we actually
did this big thing where we went through
a whole bunch of posts
where titania called out everything is
racist
yes so again this is andrew doyle who
runs the count it's a brilliant creation
and he actually put together through
titania of course
all of these articles about how
literally everything is racist yeah
like i'm i'm not kidding he does satire
but these articles were real
yeah and depressing because it was
everything right so it's like
not seeing colors racist seeing colors
racist women are racist apparently women
are women
just in general in general yeah you know
3.5 billion people
racist right what yeah remember that was
one of the articles on the list
women are yeah women in general i
remember thinking i mean well they think
everyone is
racist so yeah that means you gotta
cross the net pretty wide but
anyway the reason why i'm showing you
the absurdity of saying
future generations won't exist right but
that's that's that's what ends up
getting propped up on uh
that's what that's what they end up
putting i i'm is this a joke
i don't know i don't think it is one of
those is especially helpful
yes this makes me feel better
a little bit because things have been
what a little down but
i really really like and i'm going to
point out i hope so everyone else can
enjoy this with me is the title of
stacey abrams book
which is lead from the outside which
implies that she
is not the governor of georgia which
makes me very
i thought she said she was i thought she
was too that was 2018
she has not let go of the dream but
apparently based on the title of her
book
she's not how could how could biden and
kamala
actually win dude i don't see it and
here's why
i was thinking who in the world is less
likeable than hillary clinton and i can
only think of one person
you know who it was yeah it was connolly
harris and
i was like am i going to guess yeah you
have to guess sorry when they called her
name
as the uh choice for joe biden i was
like
you know what i feel good i'm feeling
good that made my day good
everybody was laughing dude we did a
video everybody was laughing
i did like four videos on it it was like
everybody kind of knew he was going to
do it yeah and then it was all just
like twitter was it was it was a rainbow
hand-holding kumbaya kind of everyone
agreed
everyone agreed literally everyone
everyone agreed is like everyone
agreeing
about certain incidents in that one jail
that one time not happening
there was a really funny tweet uh okay
it was i think the reagan battalion said
that the rnc newsletter talks about
liberals or whatever you know ragging on
kamala yeah and it was like
some young turks people and so and like
kyle kolinsky and then like michael
tracy
and then a bunch of people started
laughing like none of these people
are like actual democratic-based voters
yep
and kyle kolinsky responded he's a
progressive commentator for those i
don't know
wait till the republicans see what i say
about them i thought it was hilarious
but uh it was it was funny because you
actually had
you created a unity moment you know i
think camel is really something special
and i appreciate and respect her because
she hold on what did you just call her
kamala
yeah yeah i quickly corrected it there i
have a i have a hard time with her name
you have to understand that pronouncing
her name wrong
her name wrong is racism not only racism
but sexism because it shows you don't
respect
women women what was i saying oh
well it's because it's your fault for
being a bigot my racism blinded me and i
forgot what i was going to say
i'm sorry did you see was wonderful did
you see yes no
no wait i remembered okay okay what i
really like about her is that she has
found a way
to be awful to every single demographic
in different ways it's really i really
think that's what's going to bring us
together as a country
to vote against joe biden in november i
think maybe they were like
what what can we do to make the worst
possible like who are the worst people
in the world like that we have right now
oh i don't know no they did they found
warriors no they did yeah
kamala and biden yeah yeah i think
you're the worst possible candidates
the least charismatic everybody joe
biden's fallen asleep yep
and kamala is is cop mala and she's a
despotic lunatic yeah it's the issue
isn't that she is
a cop it's really not she's everything
that's wrong with
everything that they complain about
about police she has done it all
she's really made corruption like her
specialty
i mean well it's like we were saying the
other day you can get
non-policing and and kind of overboard
yep so i was making fun of kamala and
somebody tweeted at me that
tim is no longer tough on crime
pro-trump or whatever and i was like
first of all
no i like there's a difference between
saying
yes police please arrest that man who
was lighting that building on fire with
people inside yes
or like when the dude showed up in
tacoma with the rifle throwing fire
bombs
like please do not hurt these men who
are staying outside this building
and and please police and you know help
stop this man who's
throwing fire bombs and shooting at
people is the difference between that
and kamala harris who's like i'm
you know she's cackling about how
homeless mothers are being locked up
because their kids aren't going to
school
yep she's joking about smoking marijuana
because of her background while people
that she put in jail for marijuana
offenses are literally languishing in
jail if they're not fighting forest
fires because she thought it would be a
good investment to make them work for
nothing
and to lengthen their sentences for not
nothing like a dollar an hour a dollar
an hour okay yeah yeah i'm sorry
i repent i'm sorry i'm lydia i think
you're wrong yeah
yeah i think you're wrong how so you
said i'm
more unlikable than hillary ooh i think
he'll
be challenging me on that i'm i am well
i guess
if if i had to make an assessment on the
on the point system of unlikability okay
yeah let's do it
hillary's way more unlikable than kamala
yeah what makes you say that
uh i it probably has more to do with the
fact that we've seen more of hillary
okay yeah so that's fair but but
i think there was that comment that one
time that one time
they're talking about julian assange and
hillary was reported to have said can't
we just drone this guy
and then i think their response was like
it was a joke no it wasn't
that's all they did during the obama
administration what was it we came we
saw he died
yeah fantastic momentary that's just
wonderful
i like to imagine like obama he's got
like his he's got he's he's like in work
attire so he's got like a button-up
shirt with his
sleeves are rolled up of course they are
and he's like sitting on the couch with
his feet up on the coffee table and he's
like texting
and then like hillary's sitting like
smoking a cigarette and then obama is
just like
oh man there's like some guy in the
middle east and then hillary's like i'll
just drown him he's like
he presses the button just like that
that willy nilly just like
oops it was a 16-year-old american yeah
maybe you're right maybe we just need to
see more of kamala my friends
i have really good news for all of you
yeah yeah i'm excited you look thrilled
what yeah what is it do you know the
good news is i do you do not think i do
hillary clinton is back baby yes speak
of the devil hillary clinton is back he
shall appear
hillary clinton says she's ready to
serve in a biden administration
former secretary of state and defeated
2016 candidate hints
at a return to dc and wants to help fix
the us
thank you lord we need hillary to help
us fix the us
oh no we do we got that cheeto dictator
in office man
uh and all and and drumpf oh trump we
got
we got the great new york times that's
right i got one source on that now
finally calling out drumpf they got him
man they got him back you'll never
recover
hillary clinton says she's ready to
serve in a biden administration
oh um the former 2016 democratic
presidential candidate
was speaking during the 19th rep
represents summit
when she made the remarks i am ready to
help in any way
in any way and in any way i can because
i think this will be a moment where
every american
i don't care what party you are i don't
care what age race gender
i don't care every american should want
to fix our country clinton said
so if you're asked to serve you should
certainly consider that
clinton served alongside joe biden in
the obama administration as secretary of
state
her tenure was highly criticized by
republicans who questioned her handling
of the 2012 benghazi terror attack
i'm thrilled to welcome kamala harris to
a to a historic a historic you told me
it was ann historic
i did and uh they're wrong a historic
democratic ticket clinton tweeted
tuesday
she tweeted wrong haha tweeted wrong
she's already proven herself to be an
incredible public servant and leader
and i know she'll be a strong partner to
joe biden please join me in having her
back
blah blah blah we get it she announced
okay listen
i've i've i did a segment on my main
channel
talking about the potential for history
repeating itself yes
because they keep bringing up mondale
they did an article
uh then it was it was it was the new
york times right not sure
it was um oh what's her name i can't
remember the name woman who did this
but she wrote about how it's been 36
years
yes since uh a man had a woman on
on the ticket together or whatever and
hillary clinton responded with like
i'm pretty sure tim kaine and i didn't
hallucinate the 2016 cycle
and i thought it was actually really
funny that they screwed it up that bad
because hillary is
it's a woman but uh anyway
they fixed it and they send it back to
mondale because uh walter mondale had
geraldine ferrero i think i'm
pronouncing her name right yeah
something like that as his running mate
and they're likening what's happening
now a bit
to that race that is an interesting race
to compare to
a 49 state landslide so anyway anyway i
i'm rehashing this specifically for a
reason
if there was anything that could
guarantee in my opinion a 49 state
landslide
anything first we have mass riots going
on for like 76 days in portland yep got
that
that you get get this most of you you
may know this i know there's a lot of
people who
uh you'll come here you will hear me say
similar things i said on my earlier
segments
but um a lot of people come just for the
live show so i'll tell you straight up
the state police in oregon were
dispatched and
when they were the federal police
officers went back in the courthouse and
stayed there
right and then also the media started
screaming it's over as soon as the feds
left
peace even though it's not true the
riots continued they went to residential
neighborhoods
the state police just announced they're
pulling out because the prosecutors
won't arrest anybody
hmm so so now trump gets to come out and
laugh
told you so because the violence did not
stop
and he's going to come back out again
you got the violence in chicago
they have they're locking down the city
all this week oh they are
all this week yeah yeah i didn't realize
that yeah
and michael tracy journalist tweeted
don't you think
people like need to know what's
happening where's the national reporters
explaining
why chicago is doing this i couldn't
imagine being in chicago right now
donald trump says new york is in play he
says he's going to try and win new york
the first time since reagan that would
be crazy for my lifetime i was not alive
when reagan won
okay and then you know for the most of
my life we've had this pretty basic
you know electoral pattern so anyway to
my point
you've got mass riots they're great
they're getting worse
trump was right about portland yeah and
if trump sent in the feds to chicago
like the media lied and claimed he did
the looting would not have happened
yep the feds would have been able to
come out but instead everything gets
tore up
new york is is is apocalyptic it's a
ghostly it's a
ghost town it really is how many people
have left now i think it was the blue
thing behind me i think i fixed it
you fixed your you're not ready you're
no longer ready yeah i like it it was
uh right right now they're saying 13 000
empty apartments yep
it's a record since like i don't know
back in this
70s or something companies are leaving
we're like 54 or something yeah
companies are
insane so look and this is due to just
general mismanagement
but you've got politicians these
democrats actively supporting these
you know the black lives matter movement
let me tell you something
i i wanna i wanna i was gonna make a
joke and i'm gonna make the joke
but then i'm going to be serious yeah
hillary clinton
added on top of the pile of economic
collapse
mass riots kamala harris and biden gaffs
despotism and then they're like we
really need to make sure trump
landslides
let's throw hillary clinton on top that
actually makes sense and now it's like
okay that's it
the avalanche started it's like it
reminds me almost of those those videos
where people will stack stuff on people
while they're sleeping
you ever see that yeah i've seen people
do that with babies i think there's like
a bunch of blocks on them it's actually
really funny and horrible to watch
because they don't usually wake up
they're completely still and silent
well it okay babies will pro like maybe
bit too far
you know babies are okay but but don't
do that to cats yeah that's funny
yeah it's like you know they'll be like
a sleeping animal and they'll like put a
cup on its head yeah and then they'll
start stacking things
so when they wake up they do to people
that's what it feels like is going on
like the the american people were laying
were sleeping and ignoring everything
and then while they were ignoring
everything not voting and not people
were stacking things on top of them
and then finally kovid and the riots was
like a kramer
door you know you've seen seinfeld right
yeah he like pops it open and slides in
he's like oh
and then that shock has that person
sleeping covered in all this awful
garbage waking up and going ah and then
garbage flies everywhere
that's what it feels like regular
americans were sitting around
they weren't paying attention to what
was going on everything started getting
worse
all this stuff was being stacked on top
of them and then the riots bam
they wake up and they're like whoa
there's trash everywhere
you know what you know what they're
gonna do with all that garbage that's
piled up on them
they are gonna kick it clear across the
room and i'm not convinced that's not
what's gonna happen in november i think
it's gonna be a blowout well i'll put it
this way
you've got this person finally wakes up
and there's garbage everywhere
and they see the the people who are
stuck in the garbage are kicking and
jumping around and stomping in garbage
and they got one roommate who's
basically like no no no it's okay
it's okay the other room my the other
roommate's angry saying i'm gonna get
somebody to come clean this up you guys
knock it off
and they're gonna be like i'm with this
guy like clean up the garbage man knock
it off
right this idea was this they woke up so
many people
it's like we were talking about a moment
ago people i know who are who are
tweeting who normally didn't
they woke up yeah they've been like
activated
and i can't imagine they're gonna go out
and support joe biden and you know what
i don't think that hillary's new
hairstyle is personable enough
for people to be like you know what i
forgive her
i've forgotten everything she did that
was wrong look at this hair like
seriously look at this this little mom
guilt trip about doing what's right for
your country
no no no that's not gonna work i i'm
having flashbacks to 2016 and i don't
like it it's making me really unhappy i
don't think she's gonna do anything with
you don't think so
no i think she's desperate i think that
her voice is toxic
and i don't know if she doesn't realize
it or if she needs like a new press
whatever press person to like rest the
phone from her grip
because that's she shouldn't be talking
right now like i
kamala harris do you think they're
trying to make kamala harris look
likable
by bringing hillary into the picture oh
yeah it's like that family guy joke i
brought it before
oh yeah yeah where the studio hires an
ugly woman to stand next to me
so that she looks better by by
relativity or whatever that's it by
comparison
that's it and then she pulls the ugly
woman next to her the guy walks up and
goes hey meg you get less ugly
she's like yeah she pulls the girl hey
kamala did you get a little more likable
next you're standing next to hillary
clinton man and that's a that's an easy
one
so look that's a joke okay to be
completely fair it's a joke
i don't i don't think hillary's gonna do
anything maybe but i'm gonna be serious
now because
the the joke i was making was that i
said if there was
one thing that would guarantee trump a
landslide it would be them bringing on
hillary clinton
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 p.m if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode